this weekend kicks off one of the first
major in-person events alex that we've
had
in near year yeah today more than 12 000
fans
we'll head over to the las vegas motor
speedway to watch the nascar cup series
we've got kate houston live from the
speedway this morning with a preview
good morning kate
good morning tickets for this weekend's
races are completely sold out
normally about 80 thousand fans would be
able to
sit outside here at the speedway but
like you said only just over 12 000 will
be here for
the race tonight but you know what
nascar and the speedway are doing a
great job to make sure that people can
enjoy in person
as well as at all those virtual events
that are online well this morning i'm
joined by the grand marshal for
tonight's race we are with buffalo bills
running back antonio williams thank you
so much for being with us absolutely
glad to be here
yeah we're glad to have you and you know
you've been a fan of nascar for a very
long time you and your family
what does it mean to you and what does
it mean to be able to be the grand
marshal for tonight
it means a lot you know i grew up in
small town north carolina and being able
to do this tonight you know coming from
a small town in north carolina that's
huge you know i'm very excited to be
here
yeah yeah i'm sure that's just great
after watching it for so many years and
you know they have a lot of big names
coming out tonight coming out this
entire weekend really
talk a bit about some of that cross
sport appeal and what it means to
bring some other fans in from other
sports to enjoy nascar just like you do
yeah absolutely i think nascar is a
sport that's growing again it's getting
back to what it used to be and
involving other athletes in different
leagues i think that'll bring that
attention back to it and it'll continue
to
increase the diversity and and what
they're doing i think is great so i
think the inclusion of more athletes and
and different people in different in
different areas will continue to help
the sport grow
yeah yeah and you know being an athlete
yourself you understand the impact that
fans can have especially at in-person
events
what's your message to all the fans that
are coming out today to support the
drivers
just enjoy it enjoy it and uh just
realize you know maybe a year ago
you guys couldn't be here in the race so
we're slowly progressing back to
the normal i guess you'd call it um and
just enjoy it and have fun tonight
yeah thank you so much for being with us
this morning thank you well it's a
really exciting time to be able to have
fans back
in person here at the speedway the first
race kicks off tonight
at six o'clock of course you can watch
antonio williams you know really just
welcome everybody back a little bit
before then
but that will start tonight at six for
now i'm reporting live from the las
vegas motor speedway kate houston eight
news now
oh and how fun to see him with you this
morning kate thank you so much that'll
be a great weekend thanks kate good to
see